nothing has been so true in my career is
she what I know and what I know is West
Virginia
there's something about the state and
the people that live here and the
generosity that happens people aren't
afraid to roll up their sleeves and help
their neighbors people aren't afraid to
pick you up when you fall
my name is Marc Trent I don't wanna say
follow my dreams because that's we'll
get this I used to work in New York
making commercials I was traveling all
the time I was living the dream I guess
but I was working on some personal work
in my home state of West Virginia and it
involves prescription drug abuse in the
region that's one of the reasons why I
bought in a Subaru I had to get down to
West Virginia more that was my goal
there came a point where I had to choose
between my life in New York and my life
here and I chose my life here
[Music]
so when I moved back to West Virginia I
came here to kind of focus on the
projects that I was passionate about and
when the flood happened everything was
put on hold
[Music]
it was the worst flood in West Virginia
history in a sense and it happened in a
matter of minutes
I mean people didn't notice until it was
too late they were trapped in their
homes after the storm people from
everywhere all over the country came to
help that was one of the most surprising
things the way people just banded
together I'd lived in New York for so
many years I'd lost my sense of
community and then just coming home and
seeing that love and that support no one
that needed anything went without there
in the flood my Subaru it's a part of my
tool set that's just as important as my
cameras I wanted a car that I could load
my equipment and then travel around as
soon as I saw the fob door and prizes I
was like yeah I knew that this was gonna
work I appreciate the fact that Subaru
cares about the people that I care about
people like the people in my community
that they help I'm doing a new film
about the flood recovery hopefully this
documentary will be my biggest
contribution to the flood relief because
as time progresses people forget and I
want to sort of remind everybody that
this stuff is still happening
hey Ronnie how you doing behind you
buddy it's tough work yeah being back in
West Virginia has definitely facilitated
my passion projects again I'm actually
present in the state and I can make work
here and I can talk about it and I'm not
just dipping in for a few days at a time
for me it's not going out for a few
hours and taking pictures it's days in
maybe months it's its presence its
patience its honesty its commitment and
you're not just there to get a picture
you're there to learn about somebody
[Music]